le parc naturel marin ce sont les 49
mille kilomètres carrés d'océan qui nous
entoure et correspondent à notre zone
économique exclusive et pour réfléchir à
l'impact sur ce milieu de nos activités
humaines
ce comité de gestion d'une cinquantaine
demande ils sont élus professionnels de
la pêche ou d'activités loisirs membres
d'associations écologistes ou
industrielles ensemble ils ont désormais
cette espèce de concertation censé
représenter la société dans sa diversité
leur mission veiller à la protection du
milieu marin
c'est l'accompagnement des pratiques et
des hommes parce que sur ce milieu
naturel il y à des activités il y à des
personnes qui vivent qu'ils font soit
des manifestations soit de la pêche soit
des activités bannières et il faut que
ça puisse durer donc les activités les
rampes durable et rendent responsable et
accompagner ces acteurs et non pas dans
une dynamique punitive mais vraiment
d'accompagnement
le parc naturel marin est le neuvième
mise en place sur le territoire français
il transmet ses avis au préfet dont
certains pourront être contraignant il
se penchera par exemple sur
l'implantation des mouillages les
manifestations nautiques la pêche les
grands travaux comme ceux du port son
bureau constitué de 16 membres n'entend
pas faire de la figuration
on se réunit pour blablater oh non je
pense qu'il faut pas rentrer dans les
nanites mais il ya des enjeux majeurs il
faut laisser quand même la biodiversité
pour ceux qui viennent derrière on a
bien vu avec les changements climatiques
les impacts sur l'environnement
aujourd'hui nous sommes concernées tout
ça donc il faut demain matin tous
ensemble et la boe aussi des plans
stratégiques pour conserver ce qui peut
l'être sa servante le parc naturel marin
doit élaborer son plan de gestion pour
2019 puis défendre son premier budget
auprès de l'état avant d'intégrer ses
locaux à texaco cette nouvelle
institution dans notre paysage veut en
premier lieu financer des études
environnementales
le pn et même voix en effet le jour dans
un contexte très difficile ou clans
déconner sargasses étouffent notre
littoral